alors marc comme vous êtes un chanteur
on va vous faire une interview sans
pleurs on ne bouge pas mal dans le
qinghai
non
attention marc lavoine est ce que dans
la vie vous êtes plutôt paloma momo
allô maman bobo un scandale ou halo tata
bambo à la table pour vous la vis et je
vois le bio la vie en rose vous vous
êtes avec levi je ne sais pas je ne dis
ouais le joujou extra les qui voulait
préférer comme ça
ou alors comme ça rien
un peu des deux n'est pas un sport de
noirs
bon je préfère plutôt je suis suis
libéré
pour ce que vous êtes
ou alors
moi je l'aï pensé à lui sexy boy rien
vous cacher je sais tout de bois
tiens servait septième ciel le jeu
on n'a pas le dit c'est le huitième
album donne encore un mail à mes yeux